- Welcome everyone.
I'm Priya Natarajan,
I'm the current director
of the Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale.
And I am delighted to have you all
attend today's, "Distinguished
Speaker Series Talk"
with Kirk Wallace Johnson.
I'm delighted to see you,
although we are still virtual,
we were are hoping to meet you in person.
First, I would like to
take a moment of silence
to honor those who are vulnerable
in the face of the ongoing senseless war.
Our collective humanity is under threat,
and we stand in solidarity
with all of those who
are suffering right now.
So let's do just take a
few moments of silence
before we start our
celebratory events today.
Hey, so let's join in to celebrate
of the wonderful imagination
of a human mind, Kirk's,
and his book, "The Feather
Thief: Beauty, Obsession,
and the Natural History
Heist of the Century."
But before we set off,
I would like to thank Mr and Mrs. Richard
and Barbara Frankie for
their generous support
of multiple interdisciplinary
activities at Yale.
A flagship of which is the Frankie Program
in Science and the Humanities.
Thank you so much.
They are in attendance
today with Jane Frankie.
And I know that we have a draw
of a very wide audience today
from near and far,
and we are pleased to welcome
all the enthusiastic
naturalists and bird watchers.
In addition to our loyal following
who have helped us build
and sustain our community
through the very isolating
and difficult past two
years of the pandemic.
So glad to be emerging from that darkness
into health, happiness,
and light for all of us.
I just want to remind you that
we are recording this event
and that all participants will
therefore have their videos
muted for the duration of the talk.
Please feel free to type in your questions
and you may submit them at
any time in the Q&A feature
in our webinar.
Well, I want to start today
by introducing someone who
doesn't need an introduction.
Rick Prum,
the William Robertson Coe
Professor of ornithology,
and the curator of ornithology,
and head curator of vertebrae zoology
at Yale's Peabody Museum
of Natural History.
Rick is the former director
of the Frankie Program
and is a renowned scientist
and a claimed author.
Many of you might have
read his best selling,
"The Evolution of Beauty."
And I gather, he is a brand new book
that is expected to be out very soon.
His list of seminal contributions
to our understanding of
the area of evolution
and his recognitions and honors,
awards are too numerous to recount.
So in the interest of time,
I will hand over the proceedings to him
in just a little bit this afternoon.
But before I do that,
I would like to mention a
couple of our ongoing projects
in a few upcoming events.
I wanted to you about our
learning by doing project,
which showcases stem videos.
So please contribute, take
a look at our webpage,
and we have a couple of
interesting upcoming events.
We have the ongoing inference
project, talk and discussion.
The next talk will be
given by Kyle Cranmer
on Wednesday, March at 4:00 pm on zoom.
And the discussion
will be a week later on
March 16th at the same time,
with Zenna Tavares.
"The Distinguished Speaker Series Talk,"
the next one will be by Carl Zimmer,
and he will be talking to us on his book,
"Life's Edge: The Search for
What It Means to Be Alive"
on Wednesday, March 30th at 4:00 pm.
Both these events will
actually be virtual.
We are really hoping to meet
in convenient person in April,
and we are hoping to debut
that with mapping as knowing
lecture talk by the
musicologist, Victor Coelho,
on April 13th.
And we are hoping it will be in person
in the new humanities squad Durango,
and also watch the space,
the acclaimed jazz musician, Vijay Iyer.
We are hoping to have a live
event in April, hopefully.
Anyway, thank you Rick,
for offering to introduce
our wonderful speaker, Kirk.
Take it away.
- Thank you.
Thanks very much Priya.
And thank you for that
overly kind introduction.
It is a pleasure to introduce
Kirk Wallace Johnson,
bestselling author and journalist.
And if I can add, adventurer
and storyteller par excellence.
Kirk was educated at the
University of Chicago
and later did a Fulbright scholar research
in Egypt studying political Islamism.
He worked a afterwards in
Iraq with the U.S. agency
for international development in Baghdad.
And his experience in Iraq,
and following that experience
was the core of his first book in 2014,
"To Be a Friend Is Fatal:
The Fight to Save the
Iraqis America Left Behind"
This book was described by George Packer
as riveting, darkly
funny, heroic and shaming,
and was a deeply affecting book.
His 2019 book,
"The Feathery Thief: Beauty, Obsession
and the Natural History
Heist of the Century,"
the subject of today's
lecture, was also bestselling,
and usually an unusual book
in the niche of wonder logical true crime.
And that's what we'll
be hearing about today.
Kirk has a book coming out in late summer,
"The Fishermen and the Dragon:
Fear, Greed, and a Fight for
Justice on the Gulf Coast"
which is about immigrant
Vietnamese fishing communities
in Texas and Alabama.
So, exciting events to come.
Kirk's writing has appeared
in "The New Yorker,"
"The New York Times,"
"The Washington Post,"
"The Wall Street Journal,"
"Foreign Policy," among many others.
His work has appeared
several times as well
on the NPR show, "This American Life,"
including two rare hourlong
programs on these things.
Kirk is currently
a fellow at the USC Annenberg Center
on Communication Leadership and Policy.
Now, in about 2012 or '13 at
the Whitney Humanities Center,
I was sitting down to lunch
when someone asked me,
"Do you know, or have
you heard of Edwin Rist?"
I almost fell out of my chair
because I thought that I
was maybe alone in the world
to being obsessed with Edwin Rist.
My questioner told me
that she had a friend
who was also obsessed with Edwin Rist,
and was thinking of writing a book.
I soon got in touch with Kirk about that
and began a marvelous correspondence.
Soon we realized we had to meet
and Kirk visited in New Haven
for a marvelous couple days
where we talked about feathers endlessly.
And I talked about feathered
anatomy and development
and on and on.
Really Kirk had sort of
a mini graduate seminar
in feather biology over those days.
Of course, Kirk went on
to do further research,
which is the subject of the book.
So I won't go any further
except to pick one
little bone of contention
that I'm gonna raise.
And that is when the book came out,
I was portrayed
as a one dimensionally
potty mouth Ornithologist
In fact, that feature came the
teaser at the top of the hour
in the beginning of act two
in "This American Life."
So much that when my
mother's friends said,
"I heard your son on NPR."
And she asked me,
"Why didn't you tell me
you were gonna be on NPR?"
I was afraid to tell her.
But in fact, I must say in
the years with heavy rotation
of this program in the year
since, every once in a while,
I'll get an email from an
old high school friend,
or from an acquaintance
from long pal saying,
"Hey, I heard you on NPR."
You really always referring
to the same moments.
Now, well, the moment is an enthusiastic
and highly energetic expletive,
which featured in both the book
and in this point in live.
And I just wanna say now,
I had hoped for more balanced portrayal,
but I know in interest of the story
which was indeed riveting,
that's the source of it.
So I just wanted to report on that.
And I just want also to tell you
that Kirk, my mom is
in the audience today.
- Okay.
- And so I'm not-
- Watch your mouth then-
- Take it away, Kirk,
and thanks very much for taking the time
to join us at the Frankie Program.
- Thank you for that kind intro, Rick,
and you have my apologies for that.
I would just say, watch your mouth.
When you talk to a
journalist with the recorder.
I wanna thank Yale and
the Frankie for having me.
This is, I think, part of the appeal
that people have
expressed about this book,
is that it there's a bit of escapism to it
and we're in some
particularly heavy times.
And so even having written it,
I still enjoy the opportunity
to kind of dive back
into this story.
Since we have the advantage
to look at some pictures
and videos and audio,
I'm gonna share my screen here.
And I'm gonna open with a kind
of startling piece of audio
that happened during
one of the interviews.
Don't worry, Rick, it's not yours,
but this is probably two
years into my investigation.
Speaking to a South African
Victorian salmon fly tire,
who I suspected as having
some of the stolen birds
that you'll hear about.
- [Man] The fact that it happened,
I don't think is shocking all,
and it's not because of the
feverish demand or anything.
It's where something is case,
where something is really
difficult to get old of.
And there's enough people
that want to forget
about the feverish demand around it.
People are creative,
they're gonna find ways
to source what they need.
And really is as simple as that.
In terms of severity
of the crime and plea,
I dunno if you can quote on
anything, I don't really care,
but in terms of severity of crimes,
this, in my opinion,
just doesn't rate that ideally.
These are skins that are
sitting in cupboard somewhere.
Do I condone it?
No, not at all.
Anything that is wrong is wrong.
Wrong is wrong, and right is right.
It's as simple as that.
For me, the biggest shock
was that it was the Edwin.
- Okay, now I'm gonna do a
quick reading from the prologue.
I don't really like
reading very, very often,
partly because I have a
five-year-old and a four-year-old,
and I have this habit of kind of breaking
into a sing song, Dr. Sue's voice.
So forgive me if that happens,
but I'm gonna read you a brief
passage from the prologue,
just that kind of set the
scene for those of you
who haven't read the book.
This pertains to the
events of June 23rd, 2009.
"By the time Edwin Rist
stepped off the train
on to the platform at Tring,
40 miles north of London,
it was already quite late.
The residents of the sleepy
town had finished their suppers.
The little ones were in bed.
As he began a long walk into town,
the train glided off into darkness.
A few hours earlier Edwin had performed
in the Royal Academy of
Music's, London Soundscapes,
a celebration of Haydn,
Handel, and Mendelssohn.
Before the concert, he'd
packed a pair of latex gloves,
a miniature LED flashlight, a wire cutter,
and a diamond-blade glass cutter
in a large rolling suitcase,
and stowed it in his concert hall locker.
He bore a passing resemblance
to a lanky Pete Townshend.
Intense eyes, prominent
nose, and a mop of hair,
although instead of shredding a Fender,
Edwin played the flute.
There was already a new moon that evening,
making the gloomy stretch
of road even darker.
For nearly an hour, he
dragged his suitcase
through the mud and
gravel skirting the road,
under gnarly old trees strangled with ivy.
A car blasted by, its headlights blinding.
Adrenaline coursing, he
knew he was getting close.
The entrance to the market town of Tring
is guarded by a 16th century
pub called the Robin Hood.
A few roads beyond, nestled
between the old Tring Brewery
and an HSBC branch, lies the
entrance to Public Footpath 37.
Known to locals as Bank Alley,
the footpath isn't more
than eight feet wide
and is framed by
seven-foot-high brick walls.
Edwin slipped into the
alley into total darkness.
He groped his way along
until he was standing
directly behind the building,
he'd spent months casing.
All that separated him
from it was the wall.
Capped with three rusted
strands of barbed wire,
it might have thwarted his plans
where it not for the wire cutter.
After clearing an opening,
he lifted the suitcase to the
ledge, hoisted himself up,
and glanced anxiously about.
No sign of the guard.
He reached toward the
window with the glass cutter
and began to grind it along the pane.
Cutting glass was harder than
he had anticipated, though,
and as he struggled to carve an opening,
the glass cutter slipped from his hand.
His mind raced, was this a sign?
He was thinking about bailing
out of the whole crazy scheme
when that voice,
the one that had urged him
onward these past months,
shouted, wait a minute!
You can't give up now.
You've come all this way!
He crawled back down and picked up a rock.
Steadying himself atop the wall,
he peered around in search of guards
before bashing the window out,
wedging his suitcase through
the shard-strewn opening,
and climbing into the British
Natural History Museum.
Unaware that he had just tripped an alarm
in a security guard's office,
Edwin pulled out the LED light,
which cast a faint glow in front of him
as he made his way down the
hallways toward the vault,
just as he'd rehearsed in his mind.
He wheeled his suitcase quietly
through corridor after corridor,
drawing ever closer to
the most beautiful things
he had ever seen.
If he pulled this off,
they would bring him
fame, wealth and prestige.
They would solve his
problems. He deserved them.
He entered the vault,
its 100s of large white steel cabinets
standing in rows like
sentries, and got to work.
He pulled out the first drawer,
catching a waft of mothballs.
Quivering beneath his fingertips
were a dozen red-ruffed fruitcrows,
gathered by naturalists and biologists
over 100s of years from
the forests and jungles
of South America.
Their coppery orange feathers glimmered
despite the faint light.
Each bird, maybe a foot and
a half from beak to tail,
lay on its back in funerary repose,
eye sockets filled with cotton,
feet folded close against the body.
He unzipped the suitcase
and began to fill it with the birds,
emptying one drawer after another."
Now I'm gonna interrupt myself.
I'm under no obligation
to say this or relay this,
but I'm feeling generous towards
the British Museum today.
So I will say that this, of
the everything in the book,
this is the one thing that they dispute.
But, "Down in the security office,
the guard was fixated on
a small television screen.
Engrossed in a soccer match,
he hadn't yet noticed the alarm indicator
blinking on a nearby panel."
This led to a very surreal
exchange with the British Museum,
where they said there
wasn't a soccer match
happening that night.
I had to prove that there was,
and then they said that the
guard doesn't like soccer,
to which I replied, he's
British, I'm sure he does.
But anyways, moving on.
Edwin opened the next cabinet
to reveal dozens of
resplendent quetzal skins
gathered in the 1880s from
the Chiriqui cloud forests
of western Panama,
a species now threatened
by widespread deforestation
and protected by international treaties.
At nearly four feet in length,
the birds were particularly
difficult to stuff
into his suitcase,
but he maneuvered 39 of them inside
by gently curling their
sweeping tails into tight coils.
Edwin had lost track of how
long he'd been in the vault,
when he finally wheeled his suitcase
to a stop before a large cabinet.
A small plaque indicated its
contents, 'Paradisaeidae.'
37 king birds-of-paradise,
swiped in seconds.
24 magnificent riflebirds,
12 superb birds-of-paradise."
And to show you what
we're talking about here.
Okay, wrapping up the prologue here,
and then we'll get into it.
"The guard glanced at the CCTV feed,
an array of shots of the parking
lot and the museum campus.
He began his round, pacing the
hallways, checking the doors,
scanning for anything awry.
Edwin had long since lost
count of the number of birds
that passed through his hands.
He had originally planned
to choose only the best of each species,
but in the excitement of the plunder,
he grabbed and stuffed
until his suitcase could hold no more.
The guard stepped outside
to begin a perimeter check,
glancing up at the windows
and beaming his flashlight
on to the section abutting
the brick wall of Bank Alley.
Edwin stood before the broken window,
now framed with shards of glass.
So far everything had
gone according to plan.
All that remained was to
climb back out of the window
without slicing himself open,
and melt into the
anonymity of the street."
Now, When I first heard about this crime,
the two big questions
that I began with in my
investigation were these.
One, what was this collection,
at the British Museum,
the second largest in the world,
they have 750,000 bird skins,
they have miles of birds
on shelves and spirits,
hundreds of thousands of eggs.
what were they doing there?
I didn't know anything about...
I thought all there was with
the Natural History Museum
was just what you see
displayed in the cases
on your school field trips,
were they, as the feather thief claimed,
just sitting in some
basement gathering dust,
or did they have some other purpose?
And the second question is,
what on earth possessed Edwin Rist,
a 20-year-old American,
to scale the wall that night
and to steal them, to what end?
The best way to answer that first question
is to introduce you to this guy.
And I gather there are a lot
of ornithologists tuned in today,
so they'll know him right away,
but this is Alfred Russel Wallace.
The best way to get into this.
This was someone who...
There're shelves sagging
with biographies of Wallace.
So I won't do the whole run through,
but the compressed version
is he was inspired by Darwin
and "The Voyage of the Beagle"
to go out in pursuit of
an answer to the question
that was the definitely
naturalist at the time,
what is the origin of species?
And young Wallace who was
not a highly educated guy,
saved up his money and
booked passage to Brazil,
where he spent four years in
intense privation building,
a collection of specimens.
Birds, beetles, sketches, fish skeletons,
like everything he could
because the thinking was
that you go and build this collection up
and bring it back home
and spend the next part of your career
closely evaluating these specimens
and looking for points of divergence
and what info you might make.
And after four years,
he loads all of these things up on a boat
and about a week or so
into the voyage back home,
he's woken by a ship mate telling him
that the ship is on fire.
And he scampers up to the
deck and he can see the smoke
curling up through the planks of the ship,
and he knows everything is gone.
He had something like 10,000 bird skins,
like, it would've been a
career establishing collection.
As the crewmen were jumping
onto the life rafts,
he scampered down and grabbed
a couple of his notebooks
and a pocket watch and a
sextant and barely escaped.
But he returned to
London threadbare, broke,
and with really not much to his name.
But astonishingly, he wrote his way
into the scientific establishment
that published two books
within the next 18 months,
the number of journal articles,
and was sort of invited into
a lot of these royal societies
who then backed his next expedition,
which was roughly eight years
in the Malay archipelago.
Now, while he was there
in the Malay archipelago,
he was the first...
Oops, where is there we go.
Western naturalists to lay eyes on this.
This is the king bird-of-paradise.
And it was an astonishing thing to him.
He described this as having
an other worldly beauty,
an intense cinnabar red
body, a rich orange head,
deep metallic green spots above the eyes.
And he was overcome, Wallace wrote that.
He said,
"I thought of the long ages of the past
during which the successive generations
of this little creature
had run their course,
year by year being born
and living and dying amid
these dark and gloomy woods
with no intelligent eye to
gaze upon their loveliness.
To all appearances, such a
want and waste of beauty."
But then Wallace recognized
that he understood what the threat was
of what he described as,
if civilized man were to
ever discover these birds,
that he would come charging in
and basically disrupt the conditions,
the world that gave rise to
this beauty and kill it off.
And he wrote that this consideration
must surely tell us that all living things
were not made for man.
And one thing to notice,
this is an extraordinary.
I feel embarrassed describing any birds
in front of Rick here,
but just pay attention
to those tail feathers,
'cause they'll come up in a moment here.
But these are these sort of Jade discs
that in the mating display,
the kingbird-of-paradise
will kind of wobble these
things back and forth,
and it's an extraordinary
thing to witness.
Now, I'm not gonna get into
the whole extraordinary story,
but of what happened with Wallace.
But while he is there, he
basically contracts malaria
and in a malarial fever pieces together,
and the theory of evolution
through natural selection,
he's impatiently waiting
for his fever to break,
and he writes the first paper
intended for publication
to proffer an answer to this question.
And he puts it in the mail and
sends it to Charles Darwin.
I'm not suggesting that Darwin stole it,
but it did spur Darwin
into kind of accelerating
his own publication schedule
of the origin of species.
Now Wallace returned to London
with his collection in intact
and sets out out to write
this incredible book
called, "The Malay Archipelago"
which you should read if you haven't.
But I just want to touch
back on his premonition
of what would happen if "Civilized men"
would discover these birds
and that threat came
quicker than he anticipated
in the form of this.
The Victorian feather fever.
If there is such a
thing as a patient zero,
we think it's Marie Antoinette,
who wedged a diamond-encrusted
egret feather into her hair
and set off this kind of global arms race
where women were competing to show status
by wearing feathers in their hair
or entire bird skins
mounted to their hats.
This set off a worldwide destruction.
It seemed that whatever
species was in Vogue that month
would be pushed to the brink
of extra patient, at least.
By one historians account,
it's the single largest
direct extermination
of wildlife by humans.
And it was to feed this marketplace,
which was itself inflamed by
new innovations and mass media
like rotary printing presses and magazines
that were pushing these
images throughout the world,
that the inaugural cover
of Vogue, for example,
has a woman with feathers in her hat.
You can see an example here.
I mean, it might be hard to see,
but on the left, that's a
photo of an auction lot.
And I think there's 1,000
hummingbirds for sale there?
Some of the things that I came across
while researching this
book were horrifying,
I mean, coats that were
being sold that had...
Well, there was one shawl
that was made of 7,500 hummingbird
skins stitched together.
On the right was a kind of like, I mean,
it's from "Punch Magazine"
which is a kind of satirical publication,
but criticizing women's fashion
for leading to the
destruction of bird life.
But less did seemed that
I'm kind of pointing
a damning finger at women.
It was men doing much of the killing,
and it was also women that led the charge
to pull us back from the brink.
It was women that revitalized
a more dollar bond society.
It was women that founded
the Royal Society for
the Protection of Birds.
And both of these have pledges
that their members have to take an oath,
not to wear feathers
or to wear bird skins.
And this was a sort of revitalization
or some people have argued,
like a new birth of the
conservation movement
was to pull us back from bird slaughter.
The first wildlife refuge
shut up in the United States
was to cut down on snowy egret poachers
in the Florida Everglades.
At that time, in the early 1900s,
an egret plumes were worth
something like four times
their weight in gold.
Now, Alfred Russell Wallace was no dummy.
He understood
that with the industrialized
slaughter of bird life
playing out across the planet,
he began to implore the British Museum
to protect his specimens and others,
but to maintain a collection
for future generations.
He described these birds
as the individual letters
that make up the words and the sentences,
and ultimately the volumes
of the Earth's deep history.
And if we allow them to be destroyed,
then we're basically blinding
ourselves to the past.
Upon his death, in 1913,
the British Museum added his
specimens to their collection,
but the threat to them
commenced that immediately,
and World War I, there
were 200,000 pounds of
thermite bombs dropped by
German Zeppelins over London.
And World War II, there
were 28 direct hits
on the Natural History Museum in London,
which prompted the
curators then to marshal
a fleet of unmarked trucks
to basically secret these
birds out in the dead of night,
to a countryside museum
in the town of Tring,
where they were assumed to finally be safe
from outside threat.
Wallace understood that these specimens
likely held answers to questions
that scientists hadn't
even thought of yet.
And so the stakes here were huge.
No one could have imagined
that after surviving Hitler,
that the ultimate threat to these birds
would come from an American
fly tire in the 21st century.
And this leads us to the second question.
So what prompted Edwin to
climb the wall that night
and to steal these things?
And the quickest way to
show you that is to do...
This is like a compressed video here,
but this is what we're talking about.
This is a Victorian salmon fly.
These things can take upwards
of eight plus hours to tie,
and they are tied according to these
19th century books that
have kind of are revered as,
and almost sort of
monastic religious levels
in terms of like the adherence
to the particular recipes
that these flies have.
At the same time that women
were showing off their status
by wearing these exotic
birds and their hats,
their aristocratic husbands
were plucking feathers off
and tying them into these
admittedly beautiful patterns
into salmon flies, which
took on these fancy names,
like the Jock Scott, and
the Green Highlander,
and the Evangeline, and exordium.
Now, it's worth mentioning here
that what we know of salmon now
is that they're essentially color blind
when they're spawning.
You don't have to be an
evolutionary biologist
to piece together that
there's no earthly reason
why a salmon in Scotland
would ever come across a
bird-of-paradise feather
from the highlands of New Guinea.
But this was essentially an art form
that was hugely popular
in the 19th century,
kind of slipped into a very near oblivion
in the 20th century until
the birth of the internet,
at which point, these books,
resurfaced and eBay came,
and a lot of people started
finding these women's hats
in their grandma's attic.
And all of a sudden these birds
that they hadn't seen before
were available to buy.
And so this then brings
us to young Edwin Rist.
Born in Manhattan,
raised in Hudson Valley.
He was 10 years old
when he was walking through
his parents' living room,
when his dad who was a
freelance journalist,
was right at piece for popular mechanics
on the physics of casting a fly.
And he was watching an
Orvis sort of 101 video,
and Edwin walked through room
when they were demonstrating
how to tie a simple trout fly.
And there's a point in the
process where there's a technique
called Paul Marine hackleburg,
where you take a feather,
you tie it to the hook.
And then you can take an
ordinary chicken feather,
and when you coil it around
the shank of the hook,
every one of those
little fibers splays out,
and it turns something
that's very ordinary
looking into something that
is extraordinary looking.
And for trout fishing, where
you're actually tying flies
that are made to resemble the insect life
in and around the river,
there's a purpose to this.
Those feathers could be used.
These are not exotic or rare feathers.
Like I said, they're Turkey or chicken,
but they might be used to
help the fly stay afloat
on the surface of the river
to mimic the legs of the insect.
But Edwin was just unsocial by this
and raced to the basement,
found some fishing hooks,
ran to his parents' bedroom
and pulled some feathers
from his mom's pillow
and started trying to tie his own flies.
He was at the time a
already a virtuoso flattest.
And so in between studying
and practicing the flute,
he became an obsessive trout fly tire.
And his parents who
were homeschooling him,
would take him to these
tournaments throughout New England.
I've been to them,
if they sound a little nerdy, they are.
And I say this as someone
who is a fly fisherman,
but they're a picture large ballrooms
with tons of booths of
celebrity fly tires,
who are all hunched over little vices,
tying flies, and Edwin would compete
where they would tell you,
you need to tie as many
of these flies as you can
within an hour.
And he started mopping up
and winning first prize, first prize.
And it was at one of these events
that he first came across
these Victorian salmon flies.
And as soon as he saw them,
he fell in love with them,
realized that he no longer wanted to tie
these sort of ugly looking trout flies.
He wanted to tie
these extraordinarily
beautiful salmon flies.
And he started getting private tutoring
from a master fly tire up in Maine,
but he immediately was
confronted with a problem.
This 15-year-old did not
have much disposable income
when compared to the other members
of this sort underground community.
So a bird would come up on eBay,
but he was never able to afford it
because there were grown men
spending thousands of dollars on it
for their own feather collection.
So, Edwin, despite this,
I mean, he was able to use
what that community refers as subs,
but substitute feathers where
their died pheasant or turkey
or chicken feathers died to
look like the exotic recipes
in these 19th century books.
He got so good at this,
that he was hailed as
the future of fly time
in fly tire magazine, which
to my wife's embarrassment,
I've been a subscriber too for years now,
when I first discovered this story.
But as good as he was his mastery of this
was always defined by a kind of longing
for what he couldn't afford.
And so at 18, when he was admitted
to the Royal Academy of Music in London,
he receives an email right before leaving
from a friend of his and a mentor,
who said, "Hey, while you're there?
You've gotta get into this collection.
You've gotta see these birds
that will blow your mind.
Do whatever you need
to do, but get in there
and see the Natural History
Museum's collection."
So Edwin lies to the British Museum,
says that he's a photographer
who needs to take photos
of Alfred Russell
Wallace's birds-of-paradise
on behalf of a friend who's
doing a dissertation on them.
And the museum trusting
him, which to be fair,
I don't condemn them for that.
These, as Rick can attest, these are...
The curators are stewards
of these collections
and they're there to
advance human knowledge.
They can't exist in a bunker
where nobody can see them,
but that calibration
has be deviled museums
all over the world of who
gets in and who doesn't,
and how do you assess risk.
And it's certainly been complicated
by the story you're about to hear.
But he goes to train, signs
his name into the log book,
and he's deposited in front of,
I think the red-ruffed fruitcrow
was maybe the first species
that he was allowed to photograph,
and he starts snapping pictures.
But while he is there,
he also starts taking pictures
of the location of the
cabinets and the windows
and the entry and exit points.
And he's building a kind of
visual map of the museum.
Now it took me nearly
four years to get him
to agree to an interview.
But in that interview,
I asked him to describe how it felt
when he was inside the sort of private
or non-public part of the British Museum.
And this is how he described it.
So you can tell almost
as soon as he's there
encountering these, I mean, for example,
the Natural History Museum in Tring
had 48 red-ruffed fruitcrows,
at the time they were selling
for something like $6,000 per skin.
He would pull open tray
after tray of birds
and see massive,
extraordinary financial value.
But he also, as a fly tire,
saw the creative potential
that if he had these things,
he would be able to tie whatever he wanted
without having the pressure of scarcity.
So as you heard in the prologue,
but he ends up taking these things
after eight months of plotting this heist.
During those eight months
leading up to the heist,
he registered edwinrist.com,
which he set up as a sort
of online marketplace.
He ordered the diamond blade glass cutter
and other on eBay.
This part just seemed
impossible to be true,
but he created a word document
which was entitled, "Plan
for Museum Invasion.Doc"
where he sort of built his strategy.
And then after performing in London,
boarded the train, stole 299
specimens from the museum.
Of those 48 red-ruffed
fruitcrows, he stole 47 of them.
The curators think that he just didn't see
one that was kind of wedged
in the back of the drawer.
Crucially some of these species
that the numbers are smaller,
but I think he took...
I have to check,
but I think he took something
like 17 flame bowerbirds,
which may not seem like
a significant number,
but at the time,
there was something
like 30 flame bowerbirds
in all of the research
institutions in the world.
And in case, there should be obvious,
but some of these birds have been there
and preserved by this chain of curators
since before the word
scientist was even coined.
So once you steal a bird
gathered from this forest
or this island in 1850,
that bird might still be there now,
but you can't go and get
another one from 1850.
I mean, this seems blindingly obvious,
but the whole point of these collections
is to have these sort of,
almost like genetic snapshots
of what the species was like back then,
and so that we can understand
how things are changing.
So the guard did not...
Whether he was watching
a soccer match or not,
he did not catch Edwin that night.
He climbed back out, he missed
the train back to London
and spent a very kind of angst
ridden three or four hours
at this tiny train stop
with a million dollars worth
of bed birds in a suitcase,
terrified that the cops
were coming for him.
Got back to his dorm room,
spread the birds out on the bed,
told one family member
that he felt like the
richest man in the world
having these collections,
and then proceeded to
start chopping them up
and hacking the breast plates,
which are the only thing
that fly tires care about
of the red-ruffed fruitcrow.
He would hack those out.
And he took a series of approaches.
Sometimes he would sell...
Here's his website, and I have...
It's especially great to be
able to do this with Yale,
and with Rick today,
because when Rick first heard about this,
he had the foresight to
take these screenshots,
the only ones that exist,
of Edwin's website,
which were subsequently
obliterated from the web.
But these are to anyone watching this,
who was a curator or works
with these collections,
these are obviously studies specimens.
These are museum specimens
that he's posting on a public site.
He's using their Latin binomials.
He's not even using the
slang for these things.
But he would sell full birds.
One American dentist...
There's a lot of dentists in this story,
I think it's because dentists are good
with working with little
tools and tight spaces.
And so that's my best theory,
but if one American dentist
boarded a plane for London
and bought something like
$10,000 worth of birds.
All of these guys that bought from Edwin,
and we're talking about a total
of like some several $1,000 worth of staff
that the British authorities
alleged that he sold,
none of them seemed to wonder
or maybe did not want to ask
how a college student was suddenly sitting
upon the most valuable private collection
of priceless exotic
specimens in the world,
but they were quite happy
to just do the transactions.
Now here, you'll see some of
my obsessive screenshotting
over the years,
but these are private
Facebook group exchanges
where they're stressing to each other,
that you never talk about the price.
You only do this over private message.
These are birds where you can see the tags
which bear all the bio
data tied to their feet.
He would also...
Hang on, my screen just froze.
Here we go.
He would also post photos
like this to these forums
where you have to
understand some of these,
that bottom row of feathers,
six of them are $100.
And I remember asking Rick this,
but I think the breastplate
has something like
maybe 800 feathers on it
for a single bird.
And he stole 47 of them.
So you could do the math
of how quickly this becomes lucrative.
Here, this is July 27th 2010.
This is before the arrest,
before he was eventually caught,
the fly time forums that
he would sell these on
are joking about the price
that Edwin is charging
and the 3000% markup that
he's making on birds stolen
from a natural history museum.
Now, it took the British Museum 35 days
to realize that they were
actually missing specimens.
The morning after the heist,
they raced over to the cabinets
housing Darwin's birds,
and it's kind of a final blow to Wallace.
But had they cared about
Wallace as much as Darwin,
they probably would've checked
Wallace's specimens as well
and realized that they had been burgled.
But they concluded within a day or so
that it was a sort of
failed break and enter
and basically breed the sigh relief.
And it wasn't until a month or so later
that a visiting researcher came
and opened up the trays
that were supposed to be holding
the red-ruffed fruitcrows
and found them empty.
And so the museum then did an inventory,
they made the tally,
they announced the heist.
The detective assigned to the case
did a number of interviews of the staff
to rule out an inside job.
But the British Museum doesn't
like this characterization.
I can understand why,
but I think they quickly
just came to an assumption
that the birds had probably
all been chopped up.
For the life of me, I don't understand.
I've been through this many times now,
but Edwin Rist was emailing
them about the very birds
that were subsequently stolen.
He signed his real name
into their log book,
but for whatever reason,
it took 15 months for law enforcement
to finally turn their eyes on Edwin.
And that was not because of...
With all respect to the
wonderful British detective
who was running point on this case,
it wasn't because of gum shoe work,
it was because another police officer
who was not assigned to the case
but who was an avid fly tire,
went to a festival in Holland
where he saw someone showing
off a priceless specimen.
And he knew about the train heist
and he started asking questions.
And so that law enforcement officer
who I'm obligated to
protect his anonymity,
but he's the one that
tipped off the authorities
and that led to Edwin's arrest.
Now, I wanna get us to Q&A,
but I don't wanna go through every twist
and turn of my subsequent investigation,
but a couple photos here of
the crime scene evidence.
So of the 299 birds stolen,
the police recovered 102 of them
that were intact with
their labels attached,
which is a crucial detail.
The labels are cut off.
They're essentially
meaningless for research
or greatly diminished for research.
72 were intact, but were
missing their labels.
And beyond that, they found
a mountain of Ziploc bags
filled with severed parts of birds.
After the news of the
arrest and other 19 skins,
all of them missing their labels
were returned by mail anonymously.
And as far as the skin still at large,
about a third of them were still missing.
And so even though,
and here you'll see
the resplendent castles
were the tales have been hacked off
and sold off to the community.
But even though the British
Museum described this
as a catastrophic theft from humanity,
and even though they
still hadn't recovered
a huge number of skins,
they announced, after the arrest,
that, "Please the matter is resolved."
When I first heard about this
and then realized that not
only had this really happened,
because it just seemed
so impossibly strange,
but that there was still,
hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of these skins
and feathers floating around
this sort of black market,
and that the feather thief
had basically had never
spent a night behind bars,
and we can get into that in Q&A,
but he was basically
given a slap on the wrist.
He was allowed to graduate
from the Royal Academy of Music
and go on his way.
That the British authorities
were no longer looking for the specimens.
And that I was seen as
I getting deeper into,
what I kind of jokingly called,
"A feather underground,"
that they were basically just
cracking jokes about it all.
That it struck me as wrong
on a very basic level.
And so this was a five
plus year investigation
where I went all over the world,
infiltrating this community,
turning people into sources.
And I'm happy to discuss
that investigation,
but among the most
shocking revelations of it,
I'm now at five separate museum heist
that have been carried out by fly tires
in the last 20 years.
Edwin's was the worst that we know of,
but it's by no means
an isolated occurrence.
Even when I launched this book...
The first event launching this book
was at the Los Angeles
Natural History Museum,
and shortly before the event,
the head of their bird
collection took me over
and showed me a cabinet
and showed me the crowbar marks
where somebody had pried open a case
and stolen the same species of birds
that were targeted in the train heist.
There's an American fly
tire who was posing.
He won a pest control contract
with a couple museums in Europe,
and he would go in at night
and spray for insects.
And then he would take priceless birds
into his coveralls and slip out.
He was never caught.
So I just wanted to say
that this is a story
that I initially thought
was just kind of a quirky,
why on earth would people steal birds?
But it very quickly became something
much more profound about our relationship
to a changing planet
and vanishing wildlife,
and also the kind of blinders
that obsession can give to people.
Just to end it on a lighter note,
towards the end of what
was an eight hour interview
with the feather thief,
I was trying light in the mood and I said,
hey, when you go on a date with somebody,
do you feel like the need
to say, just so like,
I'm a feather thief, but I'm whatever.
And I saw his brow furrow
when I used the word, "Thief."
And I said, well, is that a problem?
Like, you do not like that word,
and this is how he answered.
I hope, hopefully you could hear that.
I dunno if the audio was good enough,
but I'm not a psychiatrist
or psychologist,
but I think the term for
that is compartmentalization.
So, all right.
So I'm gonna stop my screen share here.
And I would love to dive into
question if you have any.
But again, I'm really grateful to Rick,
and to to the Frankie's and
Yale for making this happen.
And I hope that sets the table enough here
for us to have a chat.
- Great, thanks so much, Kirk.
And I'll just say
that since nobody has to
get in a car and drive home,
we're gonna let the
questions go for a while.
Thanks, Kirk.
It's always striking
to be reminded of this,
and obviously you documented
how the worldwide impact
on scientific capacity
to study this bio diversity.
I'm really struck by that description,
or Edwin's description of himself
as somebody who really
understands the feathers.
For him, somebody really
understands the feathers
is what they materially do as
you wrap them around a hook,
not the role of feathers in
the biology, the bird, the-
- Exactly, and I imagine you probably
were pulling your hair out
when you got to this point in the book,
but I mean, he was pushing a
mountain of just junk science
in the interview where he said,
essentially after 100 years,
you can't really pull any
DNA from them anymore,
and all the real value
is really just in the height and weight
and that's kind of it.
So there were a lot of points
where I had kind your...
As you described it, many
graduate seminar I had
during the interview,
where I wanted to say, are you nuts?
But I wanted to just let
him sort of hang himself
with these comments, does that make sense?
- Yeah, well, we have
lots of great questions.
I just remind people,
if you have questions,
put 'em in the Q&A we're monitoring it.
First from Katie, is
Rist still tying flies?
- Oh, that's a great question.
One that I don't think I
can't answer definitively,
but because as you might imagine,
he and I are not really
close at this point.
But he claims that he's not,
and I have not seen any posts
of his in these communities
where you would see them.
So if he is, he is doing it privately.
- And from Judith, a question,
whatever became of Edwin's brother,
was he implicating the crimes
and theft or later sales?
- His brother is, last I checked,
principal or first chair
clarinetist at the med.
So this is a remarkably talented family.
He was not implicated in this.
And as best as I know, was not involved.
- Yeah.
- So we have a whole series
of questions, just aghast.
Amy, why wasn't he jailed and convicted?
Stanley, isn't receiving
stolen goods of crime?
Couldn't some of the fly making community
be identified and prosecuted?
I know my myself, but before we met,
I was calling Fish and Wildlife Service
talking about my experiences
of seeing specimens
that were being sold at shows,
and well, there's more to crack down.
- Well, to answer that,
and I've spent quite a bit of time
talking to Fish and
Wildlife folks as well.
The truth is that they are motivated
by rhinoceros and elephant and sexier bus
than fly tires with packs
of illicit feathers.
Now, at some point in this investigation,
I was basically just cold
calling and cold emailing people
within the agency saying,
"Why aren't you guys
paying attention to this?"
Because I was on eBay constantly.
I was pulling so many records
of sales of sites
protected species on eBay
that I had to hire an assistant
to basically build this Excel sheet.
And I shared that with Fish and Wildlife,
and it was only then that they...
I can say all this now,
I'll explain it in a second.
But they finally called me
and said that they were opening
an investigation into this.
That it was going to
be like an active case
with an agent or two assigned to it,
and would I sign on as a
confidential informant.
I can say that because I'm the least
like if there were crackdowns,
like, who do you think the guy
was that tipped off the feds?
Like, it's pretty obvious that it was me,
but the timing of it is crucial
because that phone call
happened in December of 2016,
which was the penultimate month
of the Obama administration.
And so then when Trump came in
the kind of fledgling case
just sort of was closed after that.
So it's not a priority of theirs.
And the question of how
Edwin got away with it,
it's a big part of the book,
but essentially his lawyers got him
in front of Bohert's cousin,
Simon Baron-Cohen, who is
Sacha Baron Cohen's cousin,
who is one of the leading
experts on Asperger's.
And over the course of one
hour or so assessment of Edwin,
he concluded that Edwin had Asperger's
and therefore didn't really
realize what he was doing.
Now, I've had a lot of people write to me
that Asperger's doesn't even exist
as a standalone diagnosis anymore,
but that people who are on the spectrum
often have a heightened
awareness of right and wrong.
That just because you're on the spectrum
doesn't mean that you don't recognize
that plotting a museum heist for a year
and stealing things that
aren't yours is a wrong thing.
It's a, kind of, an offensive thing.
But the brits, they were able
to basically cite a series
of precedents in British case law,
where people with an
assessment of Asperger's
were then not ever sent to prison.
And obviously Americans, we
wanna throw everyone in prison,
so I'm not advocating that,
but he truly was not punished.
He had a confiscation order
for something like $10,000 or $15,000,
and then he was sent on his way.
So there really was no
meaningful punishment here.
- Yeah, one user asked,
how much pushback have you gotten
from the fly tying community
since the publication?
- Well, it's interesting
because one thing I neglected to mention
is that the overwhelming majority
of the men who tie salmon flies,
and I say men, because I
spent years researching this,
and I did not find a
single woman who was tying.
I got excited, 'cause at one point
I saw a woman posting flies on Facebook,
but it was just her
husband using her account.
But overwhelmingly,
the men that tie the
Victorian salmon flies
do not fish at all.
They don't know how to fish,
they don't own the gear.
This is just an art form for them.
And I mean, quite honestly,
you'd have to be a lunatic
to cast a $2,000 worth
of feathers into a river
when you can catch salmon
with dog for tied to a hook.
I mean, I had some one angler
right to me with a photo
of a great salmon that he caught with...
He had run out of flies and
he tied a candy bar rapper
to his hook and caught one.
Salmon aren't easy to catch,
but they're not drawn
to these particular feathers, obviously.
So there's a very pronounced dichotomy,
the ones who don't know how to fish
and who tie these salmon
flies, they hate me,
they hate the book, "The Fly Fishermen,"
the guide that first tipped me off
to this story 10 years ago in New Mexico,
has twice had to go to
local law enforcement
for a specific death threats
that he's received in this community
for the sin of telling me about this story
in the first place,
but the other, the rest of the community,
which are actual anglers and
people who know how to fish
and who are using trout flies
and who have a kind of maybe
a more realistic awareness
and appreciation of nature
and of conservation,
they all love the book and celebrate.
But my biggest antagonists with this book
have been classic salmon fly
tires and the British Museum,
which is one of the only museums on earth
that just won't carry the book.
You can't find it in their gift shop.
So yeah, it's a strange...
I think the British Museum never...
They weren't able to step
past their embarrassment
to recognize that this entire
book was a love letter to them
and to their mission and
to their institution.
And that I spent all of this
time going around the world,
trying to track down these skins
so that they could be
returned to that museum
for the proper use of these specimens.
But I think they were more concerned
with what they call reputational damage.
- Yeah, we have a question from Raquel,
the disrespectful attitude of
the fly time community aside,
is there an argument to
be made that fly tires
also have valid appreciation
of these specimens for the
purpose of art and beauty
if not for scientific knowledge?
What if the museum were to
sell some of their extras
once the scientific
data had been collected?
- I think you should answer that one.
- Well, yes.
Well, the interesting thing
is that we never reach an end result
of when we've collected all the data,
because in fact, obviously
DNA wasn't described
until nearly 100 years after
Wallace wrote his paper
or collected many of these specimens.
And now, and in fact, we can still,
and we do get better and better
at acquiring lots of useful
DNA specimens of the things.
So that notion is wrong.
And the other part about it
is that we are incredibly highly regulated
to make collections today
requires lots and lots of permits,
which have to go through lots and lots
of ongoing regulation.
And so those permits would not be given
for the purposes of making art.
And indeed, one of the
interesting things about this
is it's roots in Victorian
mark until colonialism,
though all those feathers,
all those earls who were
inventing these flies
back in the Victorian
era were buying these
because they were available
from all of the colonies
that had have been gathered.
So it's really a return to that
kind of concept of the world
that allows this art form to exist.
And some of forms auto go extinct.
- And I think...
I was just looking at one of the comments,
but like initially
when I knew nothing
about any of this stuff,
I thought, well, isn't
there something to it?
I remember talking to
you about this, Rick.
But that here are guys
who really love and
appreciate these birds.
But it quickly...
Their appreciation for
them is in a kind of,
I've used the word to deliberately,
but it's in a cult like appreciation
where there are certain series of flies
that are supposed to only be tied
with a particular type of feather.
And when you go deep into all of this,
these guys talk about
the kind of exquisite
quality of how this feather
can be married to another feather
and the way that the
recess bends differently
than a chicken feather would and all this,
there's zero science to any of it.
And so that's where I felt
like anyone, myself included,
like at some point you
have to pick a side here.
Like, is this just an aesthetic pursuit
and beauty for beauty's
sake or do these things,
should they be used for the
advancement of human knowledge?
I very clearly ended
up in the latter camp,
but yeah.
- There's so many great questions here.
We won't get to all of them,
but I just wanna highlight,
we have Guy Curwen
author of "Mannequins
and Egos of the world"
monograph of the family.
Do you think that Rist does
not consider himself a thief
because he wasn't incarcerated?
- I don't know how to
answer that, to be honest.
I think he still believes
that these specimens
have no rightful place in museums
and that it's the curators,
and in fact, you know, the South African
that I opened this talk
with admitted to me,
and then on the record interview
that he still has many of these birds
that he bought from Edwin,
but he refuses to send them
back to the British Museum
because he doesn't care.
But also because he believes
that these curators are
doing the devil's work
and that they're pushing evolution
and all of this sort of
Satan stuff in his mind.
And also he knows
that this is not gonna rise to the level
of like an Interpol
international operation
to go and reclaim these things,
especially if the British
Museum is not clamoring for it.
And so I think if you discount
the value of the thing that you stole,
then I think it makes
it easier to discount
your own culpability in it.
And so that's my best
guess at why he could say,
he's not a thief.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, last question.
I've lost it in feedback,
but do you worry that this
may actually encourage future thefts?
- Yeah, it certainly crossed my mind,
but I will say that one of
the consequences of this book
has been, and I see that
there's a lot of curators
on the thread here,
but this does seem to have
led to something of a wake up
in the curator community where
I went to the Smithsonian
and they now have locks on the specimens
that are referenced in
"The Feather Thief."
I gave a talk in Denver
and some deep pocketed
donor at the Denver Museum
went up to the curators
at the end of my talk
and wrote a check
or committed a huge
amount of money to them
to upgrade their security
for the collection
which was not a desire of
mine, to be totally a honest,
but a sort of unofficial
security consultant
to this community where
I get emails regularly
from museums around the world
who are forwarding requests
for access to their collections
from people who they suspect
might be salmon fly fires.
And on more than one occasion,
I've had to write to
these institutions to say
like, no, you absolutely
should not let this person in
knowing what I know about them.
My wife isn't particularly
thrilled that career shift
of me becoming a museum
security consultant,
but even occidental out here,
I live in Los Angeles and occidental,
has the more lab of zoology,
and I'm close friends
with the head of that lab,
John McCormick.
He just sent me, proudly,
like a screenshot of all
of their new surveillance
and security measures
and things like that.
So I think there are probably new people
that have entered this community fly time,
but it's also, I think,
become a lot harder
to steal these things.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I'm sorry that we won't have time
to get into all the rest of the questions,
but at this point,
I wanna thank you, the
audience for your attendance
and thanks, Kirk,
and best wishes, best good luck
with the launch of the new book.
And I look forward to
that read as well as this.
And I know we'd have a
great uproarious applause
if we were all together,
but you certainly have mine.
Thank you very much, Kirk.
- Thank you. Thank you all for having me.
- Thank you, Rick.
And thank you everyone for attending.
Thank you, Kirk.
And thanks once again,
Ty and Guy for helping
make this such a success.
Bye everyone, and see you next week.